We're on problem 49.
Let me copy and paste
it into the window.
I've copied it and now
let me paste it.
There you go, problem 49.
Let me pick a good highlighter
color, magenta is good.
A student showed the following
steps in his solution to the
equation below, but his answer
was not correct.
Then at the bottom they say, in
which step did he make his
first error?
So let's see, log base 5 of 2x
squared, minus 3x, plus 1,
minus log base 5 of x, minus 1,
plus log base 5 of 125 is
equal to 6.
Fair enough.
All right, now it looks like
in this first step, he kept
this the same.
You can't mess up there.
Then he said log base
5 of 125 is 3.
Yeah, that's right.
5 to the third power
is equal to 125.
So that is right as well.
Let's see, here it looks like he
took the 2x squared, minus
3x plus 1, and he factored
them into 2x minus
1 and x minus 1.
Let's see if that's right.
2x times 2x is 2x squared.
2x times minus 1 is minus 2x.
Minus 1 times x is minus 3x.
And you have a minus 1 times a
minus 1, you get a plus 1.
So you get 2x squared,
minus x, minus 2x, so
minus 3x, plus 1.
So this is right.
So so far so good.
What does he do next?
All right, in the next
step he keeps this
first term the same.
2x minus 1, x minus 1.
Fair enough.
He keeps this term the same.
He just subtracts 3
from both sides.
He subtracts 3 from both sides
and this becomes 0 and then
this becomes 3.
Fair enough.
What does he do in
the next step?
This is interesting.
He essentially said, if I am
subtracting 2 logarithms with
the same base, that's
the equivalent of
dividing the two things.
So he kind of did a
quick step here.
So his logic here is that log--
I don't even have to
write the base 5-- but log of
2x, minus 1, times x minus 1,
minus log of base 5, times x
minus 1, that that would be
equal log of 2x minus 1, times
x minus 1, all of that
over x minus 1.
That seems fair enough.
So that should cancel out.
Oh, but that's where he
made his mistake.
What you end up with left over
when you cancel out the 2x
minus 1's, isn't one
of the minus 1's.
You're left with log
of 2x minus 1.
This x minus 1 and this
x minus 1 cancel out.
He should be left
with just the 2x
minus 1 in the logarithm.
But instead, somehow he got
rid of the 2x minus 1 and
ended up with just an
x minus 1 here.
So step 3 is where he made
his first mistake.
I don't know.
He somehow intuitively knew that
you could divide x minus
1 into this, because of log of
A minus log of B is equal to
log of A over B.
But I don't know, he simplified
wrong or something.
Who knows?
Next problem.
All right, let me copy and
paste this one too.
I'm starting to like this notion
of copying and pasting.
I don't have to rewrite
the problem.
And I can mark it up and do all
sorts of things with it.
All right, a certain radioactive
element decays
over time, according to the
equation y is equal to A times
1/2 to the t divided
by 300th power.
Where A equals the number of
grams present initially, t
equals time in years.
If 1,000 grams were present
initially, how many grams will
remain after 900 years?
So we get y is equal to--
1,000 grams were present
initially, so that's A.
So 1,000 times 1/2 to the-- and
they say, what is time?
How many grams will remain
after 900 years?
t is time in years.
So 1/2 to the 900
divided by 300.
I just substituted
A and t into the
equations they gave us.
1,000 is A, and 900 is t.
So let's just simplify
this thing.
So we get this is equal to
1,000 times 1/2 to the--
what's 900 divided by 300?
It's just 3.
So that equals 1,000.
What's 1/2 to the third power?
It's 1/8.
It's 1/2 times 1/2 times 1/2.
So we get 1,000 divided
by 8, which is 125.
125 grams are left
in 900 years.
That is choice C.
Next problem.
All right, let me see
if I have to copy
and paste this one.
Yeah, sure, they have a
chart, even better.
I've copied it, and
there we go.
Look at that.
All right.
Bacteria in a culture are
growing exponentially with
time as shown in the
table below.
Which of the following equations
expresses the number
of bacteria y present
at any time t.
OK, so growing exponentially
tells us that if I say, the
amount of bacteria after any
days, so let's say y would be
the amount of bacteria,
exponential form tends to be
you'd have your initial amount--
like A in that
previous example-- times some
number that is kind of the
exponent factor, I guess
you could call it.
The last one it was 1/2.
When you do continuous compound
interest, it'll be e.
It'll be how fast something is
either growing or decaying.
I don't know, that'll be x.
I'm just making up a letter.
It's usually x to some power t
that's usually a function of
time, some constant
times time.
This is the general form
of any kind of
exponential growth or decay.
You might see different letters
than that, but that's
the general idea.
So anyway, if we look at all of
these choices, well, if you
just look at the thing,
you're seeing it's
doubling every day.
The amount of bacteria is
So that tells us that's going
to be some power of 2.
So y is going to be-- the amount
of bacteria after any
day is going to be equal
to some initial amount.
Actually, we could just
think about it, right?
We have some initial amount
times 2 to some constant times
the day's power.
But I think if we just
take 2 to the day's
power-- let's see.
At 0 days you have
a 100 bacteria.
So y is equal to 100-- I think
this gets you there; and
instead of writing days,
let's write time--
times 2 to the time.
Sometimes there's a constant
here, but this is
straightforward enough.
When t is equal to 0, this 2
to the t becomes 1, and you
have 100 here.
When t is 1, then
this becomes 2.
2 times 100 is 200.
You could say this is
t and this is y.
When t is 0, y is 100.
When t is 1, y is 200.
When t is 2, y is 400.
So it is choice B.
Probably the easiest way is
just to look at these.
And say, wow, there's only
one-- well, two of these
choices, well, three of
them have kind of
an exponential form.
We're just like, oh, well, this
doesn't take into account
the initial condition.
At day 0 I have 100 bacteria.
This one, I don't know, it
says at day 0, I have 200
bacteria, which is just wrong.
I have 100.
You take t equals 0, and
you're left with what
you have at day 0.
So depending on how you
look at it, you
get to B either way.
Next question.
I'm running out of space.
Oh, there you go.
All right, next question.
They write, I'll write
the whole thing here.
If the equation y to the 2x
is graphed, which of the
following values of x would
produce a point
closest to the x-axis?
So if you think about it, let's
just think about how
that graph would even look.
Let me draw it here actually.
I'll draw it in a
darker color.
I can do it right on
top of the white.
Let's just get an intuition.
What's 2 to the 0?
2 to the 0 is 1, right?
Its y-intercept would
be 1 at x equals 0.
2 squared, then 2
to the 2 power.
And you were looking at
4, we'll go there.
Sorry, let's say if this is 1,
this would be 2, 2 to the
first power.
Then 2 to the second
power would be 4.
Then 2 to the third
power would be 8.
Actually, 4 would be like.
So it's going to look
something like that.
We don't have to worry.
It's going to go
up really fast.
Now what happens as you go
into the negative powers?
So 2 to the negative
1 power is 1/2.
You're going to get
right there.
2 to the negative 2 is 1/4.
So you're just going to get
smaller and it's just going to
asymptote to 0.
So that's what the graph
is going to look like.
I didn't even have to worry
about negatives, because there
are no negative numbers here.
So really, the smallest of these
are going to produce a
point closest to the x-axis.
The smallest of these
values, you want to
get as small as possible.
Let's see, 3/4 is
bigger than 1/4.
So that's not right.
5/3 is bigger than 1/4.
8/3 is bigger than 1/4.
So the answer is 1/4, A.
2 to the 1/4 power is going to
be a little bit more than 1.
It's going to be something
like that.
Anyway, next question.
Oh, I'm all out of time.
See you in the next video.